the problem of course was that the south
vietnamese government and army were so
totally corrupt throughout particularly
at that time
that they were just just absolutely
siphoning off all of the the army's
ability to fight
the corruption went beyond your
imagination
let half of the soldiers go home so that
you could pocket their salaries then you
could sell their uniforms and equipment
to the communists and get money from
that then you would have half of your
trucks you could use to haul produce and
half of your helicopters to haul heroin
and and and the result it was so corrupt
for example in tainan province that
if the 25th division commander was going
to engage the enemy
to get a shipment of of ammunition of
artillery shells he would have to make a
payment to the regional commander he
would have to get some cash and deliver
it and the guy would send a truckload of
shells up for him to fire at the enemy
ci station chief was
systematically squelching intelligence
reports about this situation this
condition
kissinger wouldn't get his aid if the
truth were being published that the
south was too corrupt to fight i held my
post open for five months when we were
shelled every day in order to keep this
intelligence flowing this top top agent
working
i called the boss on the radio and i
said we've got to get out of here it's
happening today and and arvin won't hold
i want a helicopter to come up and get
us and i'd gotten it down to one
helicopter load at that point and one
little briefcase of my last codes and
documents and whatnot
um
he said i can't do it he said washington
hasn't approved closing in yet now
i flew down to the station landed on the
embassy rooftop went down to the cia
station let's go to lunch we want to
hear what you have to say
they took me to lunch but first they
said let's stop off for for a quick key
and so they took me into the no name bar
two of my my bosses two of the top you
know guys
go into the next room and uh and lay
back and girls come to attend to them
and one of the guys is standing beside
me and a girl comes now i'm there trying
to talk to him he's saying yeah i want
to hear what you have to say go ahead
and i'm trying to talk to him about the
fact that the country is collapsing
while she unzips him and holds him out
and starts doing
we present the incredible story of the
last days of the cia in vietnam with a
man who was there and took a
participating role in it
john stockwell
tonight on alternative views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john stockwell served in vietnam for the
cia from 1973 to 1975 during the last
two years of u.s involvement in vietnam
before the fall of saigon to the
communist forces today in alternative
views we're going to interview john
about these experiences he's writing
these experiences up for a book that's
going to be published next year by
norton press so we'll give you today a
preview of this book and we'll talk with
john about his experiences in vietnam
do you want to begin by discussing how
you arrived in vietnam and some of your
experiences during the vietnam war in
that country yeah this was the
this was the period of my government
service that
that shattered my my ideals my
romanticism my
my it didn't exactly share my shatter my
own principles but it shattered my
idealistic vision of what my
my government my country was all about
and particularly the cia was all about
this is where
i i got to a point where i could no
longer rationalize what we were doing
what i'd seen before vietnam in africa
we were not doing good for the united
states or anyone else but neither were
we doing great enough harm
that i couldn't be offered rationales
that would keep me going for a while
longer
but the vietnam thing the cynicism
the the moral corruption and
professional corruption that existed in
vietnam now we're talking about
uh 73 to 75. i went right after the us
troops were finally pulled out and i
came out with the evacuation in april of
75
the first part of the period
was actually one of success and optimism
vietnamization was working this was the
line of the government and kissinger and
ambassador martin
trying to make it happen trying to make
it appear that it was working trying to
give a sense of confidence and optimism
and when did the north vietnamese began
their military offensive and how did
that impact on your experiences as a
uscia officer there and on u.s policy
they began a serious push in the spring
of 74
and
and the delay was really just how long
it took them to get their armies
organized and sort out their new
strategy and realized that the political
struggle would be part of it but the
fighting wasn't over and read gear for
war
and and try to claim more territory
capture more
territory and at the same time in this
in the spring of 74
henry kissinger and ambassador martin
they wound up destroying vietnamization
themselves
probably had as much negative
influence on its outcome
as anyone including the north vietnamese
they were pushing for another billion
and a half in aid for south vietnam
for the army of south vietnam and for
the
um
the government and the administration
the problem of course was that the south
vietnamese government and army were so
totally corrupt throughout particularly
at that time
that they were just just absolutely
siphoning off all of the the army's
ability to fight
the corruption went beyond your
imagination their ability to squeeze
millions and millions of dollars out of
the stuff that we were pumping in
through the pipelines steal it take it
siphon it off
let half of the soldiers go home so that
you could pocket their salaries then you
could sell their uniforms and equipment
to the communists and get money from
that then you would have half of your
trucks you could use to haul produce and
half of your helicopters to haul heroin
and and and the result it was so corrupt
for example in tainan province that
if the 25th division commander was going
to engage the enemy to get a shipment of
of ammunition of artillery shells he
would have to make a payment to the
regional commander he would have to get
some cash and deliver it and the guy
would send a truckload of shells up for
him to fire at the enemy if you wanted
the artillery the big 175s and 155s and
eight inch artillery pieces to come up
to your province to support you in a
battle you'd have to go down and make
payments to the the artillery commanders
if you wanted air support you'd have to
make payments to the
vinaf to the air commanders and with
that kind of corruption the south
we on the ground were were really our
our lives were at stake i mean these the
people that defended us we had an
interest in knowing how well they could
fight
and and they couldn't
now the congress was was pretty much
aware of this and the mood of the
country was just to get out and
kissinger and martin were saying
loudly and continuously that if we don't
get a million a billion and a half aid
the country is going to go down the
drain they cannot hold unless they get
this aid if you don't give us this age
you're going to be writing the whole
thing off as a bad debt
now they were also ordering the embassy
analysts and the ci analyst to write
reports that would support this
they were selecting out of the reports
that we would write and forward the ones
that would support this and and and
squelch the ones that would say anything
different
so
and and all of our reports eventually in
one form or another were either leaked
to the public or delivered in various
forms of liaison papers to choose
government
so tu and his government his commanders
were all reading
kissinger's and and martins and polgar
the cia station chiefs stryden screaming
claim that if we don't get the money
this country's had it they can never
stand
and they didn't get the money the
congress shut it off and during the
summer of 74
up country
we really it was really like a cold rain
hitting a bunch of people at the beach i
mean just
everybody really pulled in and a sense
of doom hit
we had in the spring of 74 we had
communist cadres talking to us and
people sending word and we didn't really
make a lot of dramatic recruitments but
there was a sense that we would and that
people were trying to
keep lines open to us
through intermediaries a relative a
brother coming in and saying my brother
and bringing documentation and my
brother's a battalion commander and he's
not all that hostile to the south and he
would you know wouldn't mind having a
dialogue going
with you you being the cia or the
the south intelligence services we had
lots of these little leaders
uh going
they dried up in the summer of 74. boy
just all of a sudden people they just
the courier wouldn't go or he would come
back or he would you know the guy wasn't
there there was nothing to say they all
dried up and all american troops were
out of the country by them so just you
and some other cia officers most yeah
the american combat troops were out of
the country the d.a.o had maintained a
large presence and a lot of the the
technicians department of the army the
the defense attaches office
which which mind you it was eating 250
million dollars a year in overhead out
of the aid we were given was just to
maintain the swimming pools and px's and
commissaries even after our soldiers
left had this incredible overhead of the
defense attaches office
what were you supposed to be doing up
country as a cia officer at that time
the the policy had been to
keep the the ci's presence up to force
there had been about 600 officers in the
country
and
when the army pulled out by decision
they kept the ci up to strength because
they said if we pull out the invisible
government
as well as the military it'll truly be a
signal to few that we're you know we're
letting we're going to let the country
go
so they kept us all there in strength
even though there wasn't enough work to
do for 600 people
we had in saigon there were 70 or 80
people and enough work for about six
serious case officers
we had the same satellite bases
throughout the provinces of the country
that had been there during the height of
the war
my post was it had more people than we
needed
but it was perhaps an exception in terms
of importance because it was it was ten
in it was on the highway that went right
up into cosmon the prg to the the
communist organizational headquarters in
cambodia and then that to a degree even
moved down into tainan province after
the ceasefire
so the flow of their agents their
corruption their their money
payments from the the bank of saigon
going up the road would go right in
front of my compound literally to go up
to cosmon and it was our job to try to
tap into this and get a get a sense of
you know of intelligence reporting on
on who they were and what they were and
in fact we were quite successful in uh
not in terms of numbers but we had some
agents that in fact
gave us for example the resolution of 75
the paper that came out in
in 74 that mapped out their new
offensive
which they they saw it as as to increase
their territorial holdings to get two
more provincial capitals
and then
consolidate
and then from that the next year in 76
they would launch the final offensive
they they didn't have any idea in
november of 74 that they would succeed
six months later and win all together
they had
their assessment of arvin in south
vietnam was that it was stronger than in
fact it was if they had asked me i could
have told them
but i was trying to tell my government i
was trying to tell my chief of station i
was trying to send reports back to
washington and
the reports would get to saigon and they
were stopped
we had
truly some fascinating
horrifying but but symptomatic of the
corruption of the cia
policies working then where the ci
station chief was systematically
squelching intelligence reports about
this situation this condition
kissinger wouldn't get his aid if the
truth were being published that the
south was too corrupt to fight
uh martin wouldn't get his policies
pushed if anyone in the embassy was
reporting this the truth the rod of the
thing so martin was trying to downplay
and this is a very strong-willed
vindictive ambassador if you crossed him
he would absolutely freeze you out
if you played with his line he could
take you know very good care of you
and he was he was a a regional commander
a consul who would come in with a report
about corruption just the fact that he
would dare to report about it would make
martin so angry that he would uh just
shut the man out the man would never set
foot in his office again
uh tom polgar the station chief actually
was touring the country getting us
together in groups saying i don't want
any more reports about the corruption in
the south vietnamese army i don't
believe it i don't accept it if you
insist on sending them in i'm going to
tear them up if you insist after that
i'll put notes in your files that you
can't follow instructions
and
you know a
gs13 a major in the field
when you've got the the pope you know
the gs18 ci station chief who walks with
the kissingers of the world
uh putting an edict like that on you you
just don't report the information
anymore now some of us still tried
um and the stuff just died the chief of
base in the delta now this is a super
grade this is like a one-star general he
insisted on putting together a studied
report of the corruption and the
ineffectiveness of arvin
and this put pulgar in a difficult
position because this man had enough
horsepower that it couldn't completely
be ignored
it was i mean from me polgar could just
just sort of
step on me a little bit and drop the
report but coming a study of this kind
coming from someone with that rank
uh would get some credence in washington
and polgar managed to kill it as well it
never went it was never forwarded to
washington
so when the offensive came the
communists were more successful than
they ever dreamed they would be
our government kissinger and martin and
polgar
were shocked and also
they tried as long as they could just to
pretend it wasn't happening
meanwhile us up country we were
tainan was one of the two provincial
capitals that the communists planned to
take it was going to be their provincial
uh capital from which they launched the
next offenses that's where you were
that's where we were so we were watching
this offensive develop with great
interest
and then
what happened was the communists
planning to attack teen inn
they had a high penetration of two's
office
and then they had another remarkable
intelligence asset i'll tell you about
it just a minute you wouldn't guess who
but
as impressive an intelligence asset as
you could possibly dream of getting
that was telling them exactly what the
u.s knew and what the cia knew which
meant that we had their resolution of 75
which meant we knew about their
offensive which meant that we were
waiting for them to attack tainan
so they pulled a faint and instead
attacked attacked bombit attacked the
central highlands and caught arvin off
off guard
and the first collapse of arvin was
there and then it spread you know like a
panic across the rest of the country
we're sitting up there in ten inn with
these seven divisions around us the
artillery implant in place knowing that
they've targeted tainan waiting for the
attack to happen and we listen on the
radio as as bandwidth is taken as the
americans there don't get out as they're
hiding in the back of the house talking
to the air america plane upstairs saying
you know their tanks in front of the
house and we've got to talk in a quiet
voice and we'd better cool it down
because some people are coming in the
front yard
for three days until they their
batteries ran out and then eventually
they
they were captured they were taken and
we're listening to that
waiting for ourselves to be overrun
while our leaders are refusing to
acknowledge the fact that they're that
anyone's ever going to be overrun
now tom polgar
after mr1 da nang and way had collapsed
in that
incredible debacle of hysteria and panic
and arvind units collapsing and and
gunning down the population and mr2
tom polgar even when the communist
forces are closing on saigon he's still
coming to benwa which is my regional
capital and canto saying things are
actually looking optimistic we're
actually greatly encouraged by the
situation
now
you know it's a difference between when
you're talking to your cheerleaders and
when you're talking to your your your
linesman you know it's it's we were the
pros on the ground
and uh he needed to come and talk to us
about okay here's what's happening this
is you know grim we're taking these
precautions
and then having done that we would
accept the fact that to the public you
might want to rant and cheer a little
bit or put on a a front
uh but he was telling us this
which apparently you know i mean he was
committed to the fact
and then after we were collapsing we'd
close tainan he was saying well saigon
is going to hold saigon will be
permitted by the communists even when he
gave up the fact that arvind could
defend them he was maintaining that
saigon would become a hong kong a free
city a free port that with a
provisional government and that the
communists would permit this so that we
wouldn't have to flee so they could
paper something together so that that we
would help we would give them you know
reparations to reconstruct the country
so we would give them uh technical help
in pumping the oil from the south china
sea
now
it might even be that in retrospect that
they would have been wise to do that but
the truth was they'd been struggling for
five decades and they had whipped you
know they'd seen the japanese league and
they'd whip the french and they'd whip
the americans and there was just no way
that they were going to forego the
ritual of victory taking saigon
and all of our real intelligence sources
were telling us it's tanks in the
streets of saigon as soon as possible
and then next month and then you know
next week
until eventually they they closed on the
city and polgar had to flee now
to jump back a little bit
uh
uh
pulgar was because he wouldn't accept
the fact that the country was collapsing
he wouldn't let us prepare evacuation
plans
you simply were not permitted to prepare
realistic evacuation plans
so when da nang fell the chief of base
there being loyal to him
three days before da nang fell he was
still denying it was going to fall and
it was no surprise i mean arvin was a
rabble way had fallen the first division
was in total chaos
it couldn't defend anything
all of the realists there were saying
hey this place is going to go tomorrow
or the next day or the next day and the
chief of base supporting polgar is
running around saying we're going to
hold there's nothing to worry about
let's be cheerful
okay the communist forces pressed on the
city arvind took off by ships and boats
and planes and whatever they could do
the ci fled but it left all its
vietnamese employees behind
then the same thing was repeated through
the central highlands and through
nyatrang and mr2
leaving the vietnamese behind but also
leaving the safe houses full of
documents behind that had the names and
identities of everybody who'd worked for
the cia and the codes and everything and
in one case in placo the three ci
officers fled they they got the word
from their agent that arvind was fleeing
and they got on a plane and left and
they didn't even tell the americans
there with them the state department
officers
that they told them they were leaving
but they didn't tell them that arvin had
made a decision to bail out and flee
so arvin is panicking fleeing the city
the ci flees
and it leaves the state department
people behind without telling them what
it knew about captured by the
no those they got out uh those state
department people did get out no thanks
to the cia but in that case as well the
cia left behind the files that
identified their vietnamese employees
and their and their agents and sources
in yatrang the same thing happened the
chief of base there uh it has to be one
of the most cowardly incidents in u.s
history
he turned on his and in the entire
history the stuff that's not put in the
history books of when you know colonels
rather than people mutiny and the stuff
that we pretend doesn't ever happen in
our country but of course it has
this is
truly he he turned on his vietnamese
people he decided that they were not
worthy of his you know respect he had a
policy of leaving him behind which was
polgar's policy and bill colby's policy
in washington
uh he dumped them he left behind safe
houses full of the documents once again
that identified them
to get clear of them he told them in one
instance that that they should come you
know everybody's leaving in the morning
on planes and told them where the pickup
point would be but gave them a false
pickup point so they would go to the
wrong side of the strip
when he went to take off
he had some managed to follow him and
they actually fired on them with machine
guns
no no he fired on them
so they wouldn't crowd on the helicopter
so he could get get away
he didn't even pay their last month's
salaries so that they would have enough
you know cash to because there was still
commerce and boats and what so they
could pay their own way to get out you
know out of the region and left them now
three weeks later the first communist
forces entered the city
he fled in this total hysteria and panic
and dumped his people
and three weeks later
the first communist forces came in the
city and was that the region you were
actually in no this was mr2 which i was
an mr3 and this was right north of us
now in my place i you know to heck with
them whatever they're doing and i saw
this and it was shocking because i
played chess with these people i played
rugby you know we went to dinner i mean
these were my professional colleagues
and i saw what they were doing
throughout the north
of the country
i was committed to try to save our
vietnamese employees i saw no reason not
to and so in my own post i worked up a
plan early on a contingency plan on how
we would get them out
i got them out i got all of them out i
got all of the files out or burned
all that i left behind was the desks and
air conditioners and whatnot which we
left behind throughout the whole country
when i got down to bienwa in in order
the chief of base there was supporting
polgar once again and and colby's
policies of dumping the vietnamese to
make sure that myself and a couple of
the other case officers who who were
devoted to the principle of saving our
vietnamese employees which we easily
obviously could have done
they brought in the case officers from
mr1 and mr2
and they put them in charge of us in our
own region we had been running up for
you know the chief of operations the
deputy chief of operations the chief of
this office the chief us the structure
they brought in these incredible cowards
who had panicked and run and put them in
positions over us
to manage us
during the evacuation of mr3 to make
sure that the principles of dumping all
our agents would be adhered to to keep
us from coming up with plans that would
have gotten our people out and did they
achieve that they did indeed dastardly
yeah and and
things like for example i got some boats
there was an admiral who had retired
there and gotten some surplus ships and
was had a little company going and when
he saw it was collapsing
he gave me two of his landing craft that
were enough for me to take all of our
vietnamese out to sea with all of their
families
and i got the ships and i got some some
rice and i got some water and i got i
went to get some machine guns in case we
had to fight our way through some hot
spots going down to the
river now i wasn't doing this secretly
i you know i talked to the boss it was a
contingency plan he said you're not
going to use them we're going out from
saigon but go ahead and get them in case
we get cut off
so i got them and i had them there and
then he decided when i went to get the
machine gun so we could fight our way
down if we had to if we got cut off or
something
he put me on a helicopter and took me to
the
you know landed on the embassy and went
down to polger's office
and asked for authority to have me
arrested and thrown out of the country
yeah okay because he said i had this
mutinous uh effort afoot that would
endanger the safety of the whole mission
and start a giant panic and everything
polgar asked me what my plan was what i
was up to
uh because he liked me and he was
astonished you know that i would be a
mutiny or something
and i told him a plan he said that's a
great plan you know what's wrong with
that he asked my boss and my boss said
what's wrong with it is stockwell wants
to go down the river with them in the
boats and the polgar said well and the
boss said remember we just lost
this guy up country and they had since
another case officer on a suicidal
mission of country and left him
strangled and didn't get him out and he
was captured just the day before and so
he said see we can't lose another one
and pogo said oh yeah we can't risk that
so he agreed that i wouldn't take the
ships down to sea
and i went back to vienna thinking well
that's all right my boss is leaving
today for bangkok
when he's gone i can take the people out
to sea
but the son of a [ __ ] before he left
the last thing he did was he he gave my
boats to the province chief
so that our people would have no way
they could get out to sea he took away
the means and the province chief put his
soldiers on them with arms so there was
nothing that i could do
or that they could do no way they could
get out and then he left the country
that was his last official act
now
to back up to this other source that
hanoi had of what was you know what we
were doing the source was tom pulgar
the ci station chief
now he was hungarian born oh yeah this
is what like i say the corruption
was
boggled the mind but he was hungarian
born
came to the states when he was in his
teens had spoke with a heavy accent
shortly after he came there the
international commission for control and
you know the iccs
had four countries of which hungary was
one
and these two hungarian colonels which i
don't know i don't think he knew them
from his childhood but they spoke to him
with the accents with with his mother
tongue
they became buddies polgar and the two
hungarian intelligence officers
targis and toth i think their names were
they convinced him that it would be in
the united states interest if he could
tell them
how the u.s felt about this and how the
u.s felt about that
and he got in the habit of it now
headquarters knew he was doing this all
the headquarters kept sending cables
saying we have serious reservations
about what you're doing
he got so involved in telling them what
we were doing that he was giving regular
briefings
he would take the briefing charts that
we used for visiting uh national
security council people for the senators
who had top secret clearances he would
take those same charts out and brief the
hungarians who of course were telling
hanoi that was the understanding
it got so bad in his compulsion to tell
them everything we knew faithfully
charging out there to brief them that
even one day he took the chart that
included the identities of our top
agents in the country our spies
and he took this thing i didn't have
their names but it had the descriptions
of where they were in the nature of
their information
so he could brief them so he could say
you see this guy in cosmon and this guy
in the prg and this guy in hanoi this is
the information therefore we know this
that what was his motivation for doing
this was he actually a double agent or
was he just thinking he was
accomplishing well something worthwhile
over the us no one would of course
want
the liable laws and everything being
what they are would want to go public
and say that they believe the man was
recruited i mean that's obviously
ridiculous except
that everything he did in terms of
briefing the hungarians was absolutely
damaging to to what to our position to
our security to south vietnam security
it enabled
the communists to re-gear their
offensive and launch the surprise attack
on the central highlands instead of
tainan as they had originally planned
and and we'll never know how many of our
agents he gave away when he briefed
about the agent identities to this day
we you know as we fled
we didn't know what happened to these
agents and which ones were wrapped up by
this guy now their their line which he
bought was that it would be useful if
hanoi knew what we
and he just flat got in the habit he was
just excited about running off and
telling his hungarian buddies about what
we were doing and what we knew we would
write a top analysis to headquarters if
here's our latest sense
of the situation and he would take it or
a version of it and brief his hungarian
buddies and he knew all the time that
they were giving this information to
absolutely now
that was on the one side he was giving
them our best information
and just think how much hanoi would have
paid for that to recruit a source
millions and millions of dollars to get
that information
now
that's on the one hand what he's paying
or what he's doing what the information
that he's giving the other thing is what
they were able to get him to do for them
which is they convinced him that we
would have this free city that the
communists didn't want to humiliate the
united states
now this was total fraud and we knew it
with our penetrations were telling us
that no no it's tanks in the streets of
saigon
he permitted them to convince him that
there would be no humiliation the u.s
would not be required to leave
and he decided to believe that instead
of us his own intelligence officers and
our reports
so that he wouldn't permit us to prepare
for the evacuation he wouldn't permit us
to get our people out he wouldn't permit
us to act as though the obvious were you
know what was obviously happening that
the south was collapsing and the north
was taking the place
so he
systematically
thwarted our efforts to conduct an
intelligent evacuation and this of
course at every stage of the way
this worked
strongly in the communists interests
because we were not taking the
precautions that could have been taken
the planning that could have been done
the falling fallback positions to fight
a better fight
were all being thwarted to whatever
extent he could deliberately thwarting
us from from doing these things
now
he was able to get by with this because
ambassador martin
had such an ego that he just could not
accept the fact that he might be
presiding over the end in vietnam in the
first u.s defeat and everything he just
simply couldn't accept this
and so his policies were compatible and
he loved to hear
the cia station chief coming in and
saying no no we're not going to be
humiliated
they've the communists have captured all
this territory but they're not going to
capture and then when the next part
would fall they're not going to you know
and they're not going to take cycle so
martin was receptive now martin was also
being set up by the french ambassador
whose chancellor was next door
and the french ambassador was saying
that the communists were in contact with
the french to save humiliating the
united states and having a decisive
victory which would work ultimately
against the interests of the of the
vietnamese that they were going to work
through the french to partition the
country into the old original forms that
the french had put it into of cochin
china and annam and and tonkin
and that south would become close in
china again you know well if you just
think for about you know 10 seconds the
vietnamese were not likely to go back to
the original french colonial structure
when they had victory in their grasp
but martin chose to believe this man and
why did the frenchman maintain this well
egomanian meddling
trying to embarrass us for one thing uh
the the ambassador was a busybody and a
liar and a manipulator
he got martin to put a hotline telephone
from martin's office to his own office
but to keep his staff from knowing about
it he had it put in his toilet
so in you know his own offices so
martin's sitting there talking to him 10
times a day which about the latest
gossip it wasn't true but oh yes we're
in touch with the communists the
communists are saying this communists
are saying that don't worry i assure you
um you know martin on the phone talking
to the guy in the in the french embassy
bathroom about what about fantasies
about what the french would like to have
the americans think was going to happen
how did you find out about this polgar
situation then
we um
the first breaks are
are ideas i had about it was while i was
there
i had
i was handling some top operations that
would have top analysts in the station
come to the meeting so they could
help us ask the right questions and
these were people who were sitting in
polgar's office so because of teen in
and because of the operations i had i
had a direct link to the top of the cia
station
in addition to which i was wise enough
i was close enough to saigon i could get
into town once a week or so it was an
hour and a half drive
and when i would get in i would make it
a point to see the people that i could
and keep up with the gossip so to speak
the number three man in the station i
had worked for him twice in africa he he
his son called me godfather sort of and
you know there was close relationship
there and i would always stay at his
house when i was in saigon and then a
couple of the top analysts including
frank snep was working with me in my
operations and then there was another
guy who was a good tennis player who was
sitting right in polgar's office and i
played tennis with him
it's not covering this story in his book
because that went into details of this
beyond the details that i knew but i
knew that the situation i mean we knew
it i knew it those of us who were that
involved knew that polgar was seeing the
hungarians and briefing them and talking
to them
it was kind of maddening to people it
violated every sense of anything you in
a professional ethic you could possibly
have now
where it gets really tricky trying to
figure out polgar's motivations
and and what he was really up to and
what he really believed
he wouldn't let us prepare for any
evacuations whatsoever
now mind you he left himself
in great panic at about the 30 or the
29th i think it was the 30th of april
um
on the 7th of april
now mine three weeks before three long
weeks before while he is still coming at
the time he's still coming to bienwa and
canto
telling us that things are optimistic
rosie he's very encouraged about the
situation
he ordered his own personal valuables
to be packed and shipped out of the
country
and for two weeks after that he was
stonewalling us saying there will be no
evacuation
and then in the panic of the last week
he was still
paying lip service to his position but
letting evacuation start to happen in
great chaos and confusion did he
snap for libel when schnepp broke this
in his book
no way he could sue snap had been
his the closest analyst to him
snap-headed all documented
no wouldn't cia ever do anything to him
or is he just uh he went on
the chief of base and mr1
and the chief of base and mr2 who had
been responsible for dumping their
vietnamese employees and leaving the
files behind
went to saigon where they were put in
charge of the standing officers in
saigon they were given the highest
positions in the cia station there
when they all came out including the
great coward in my own military region
who took my ships away from me and kept
me from saving our vietnamese
he got a high position
back in washington both of those other
base chiefs got high positions
polgar became chief of the mexico
station which was the largest most
prestigious station in the cia
the chief of base in kanto broke the
rules he took ships just as i i had
planned to do
and because he was away from saigon he
waited until the last minute and took
everybody down the river in his ships
and got all of his people out
he did not move on to a higher position
in the agency afterwards
the guy who was the saigon based chief
he had
he had the clandestine radios and some
clandestine activities in saigon
when they pulled in the guy from kent
from nyatrang and put him in charge of
this guy
they made they made the coward from
yatrong base chief and they shunted bill
aside
bill didn't get upset i couldn't believe
that he wasn't screaming and yelling a
little bit but he was real cool and
later i found out why it was what he did
was he came up with a scheme
which he was able to sell to polgar
saying okay we want to keep the radios
going if you're going to have an interim
city here a hong kong or free city we'll
want the clandestine radios working i'll
put him on an island offshore so give me
the authority and he got the authority
and he quietly moved all of his
employees to this island offshore
knowing there wasn't going to be any
radio thing but just as a ploy to get
his people out to evacuate them
eventually so he took everybody he
wanted to out put him on this island and
then a week later when the country
collapsed he took him out to see in the
navy and saved all of his people
he did not move on to high position back
in washington john to return to the sort
of framework of the narrative there was
a rather rapid collapse wasn't it of the
south vietnamese effort about how long
did it take the communists once they
started toppling these different regions
of south vietnam to eventually move into
saigon and could you tell us a little
bit about your final days in saigon and
the attack evacuation the attack on
bumwitut which was the first major
offensive attack of this offensive in
the central highlands uh began on the
10th of march
and we were all gone by the 30th of
april
so the entire length of the country they
fought all of the battles crushed all of
the arvind units from north all the way
down to the south in six weeks time
which is rather remarkable considering
they've been fighting for years
for decades right blitzkrieg you
couldn't possibly
uh at the time there was a sense of
delay i mean we would have days where
nothing would be happening and we would
be wondering what they were waiting for
well they had to re rethink all of their
plans and strategies
move armies hundreds of miles through
the jungles
uh bring extra divisions down from the
north when they saw they had a chance to
win the whole war then they they they
launched the offensive they it was an
amazing logistical feat what they pulled
off in six weeks time there was nothing
that happened in world war ii
with patton and the armies across europe
that compared with that given the
handicaps that they were they were
working against of jungle and terrain
and fighting battle after battle and the
south vietnamese army just collapsed
they never really mounted a counter
offensive or
like a v resistance like a vase hit by a
sledgehammer so your analyses on the
field of the cia of the total corruption
i was under the south vietnamese army
must have been more or less i was
vindicated in everything i said that was
happening as it happened and afterwards
yeah
after the north had fallen then the
communists came down renewed their plan
of taking tainan and using it as
provisional capital to launch the final
offensive against saigon
they very soon decided that they didn't
need tainan and they could attack saigon
directly
but we of course didn't know that they
didn't know that so at one point they
came up into town uh preparing to take
us they had their units there their
artillery sited in beginning the forays
and raids on the fringes of town and
ready to go and
i at
every source we had the high ones and
the little agents going back and forth
were all saying today or tomorrow the
attack begins well mind you every place
that had been attacked in the north had
collapsed instantly so there was no
reason to think that we would hold we
had about seven divisions against us in
one division defending and it was
notoriously corrupt division
uh i sent word to the boss saying i've
held long enough now mind you
uh five months before they had declared
tainan a free fire zone
in order to get the population out of
the way
and they they had ordered the people to
leave and then fired shelves every day
to make the people get the message and
leave so the population had evacuated
and we were shelled every day now
we being the downtown area where myself
and the police and the irving command
was in the province chief
this is what i got the medal for
afterwards the medal of merit the second
highest medal in the intelligence world
was because i held my post open for five
months when we were shelled every day in
order to keep this intelligence flowing
as top top agent working
i called the boss on the radio and i
said we've got to get out of here it's
happening today and and arvin won't hold
i want a helicopter to come up and get
us and i'd gotten it down to one
helicopter load at that point and one
little briefcase of my last codes and
documents and whatnot
um
he said i can't do it he said washington
hasn't approved closing ten in yet
and i said well i suggest you get on it
i mean he should have you know been on
top of that long before i i didn't
suddenly say this i've been talking to
him three times a day as the situation
had deteriorated i've flown down i
briefed him
and this is paul guy is your boss no
this is the regional chief but even
before that
about three weeks before this crunch
time
i flew down i ordered a helicopter and i
flew down to saigon to brief pulgar and
his the top men in the station
on the fact that uh that the south was
going to collapse about the time of
bombing to it i was
uh
my message my reason for going is that
you know the effluvium that they were
putting out of saigon
uh i i that wasn't my business what they
were telling the world or even what they
were telling washington but i wanted to
have a showdown with them and say hey
fellas you know
between you and me
i want you to look me in the face and
admit you know this country is breaking
apart it's about to go
tainan is a targeted place i'll hold my
post open and keep the intelligence
flowing but i want to be sure that
you're not blowing smoke up my backside
i want to make sure we understand each
other and that when the crunch comes the
helicopters will come in and get us now
i flew down to the station landed on the
embassy rooftop went down to the ci
station
polgar was running down the hall and the
other guys sort of stood me out for a
little while and then they said let's go
to lunch we want to hear what you have
to say
they took me to lunch but first they
said let's stop off for for a quick key
and so they took me into the no-name bar
and uh the no-name bar was just that
down an alley a villa with a fence and
you went in through it and the living
room had been made into a bar and the
dining room area kind of a big palatial
dining room area had had these little
stalls and booths put around the side
without the tables and the specialty of
the house was [ __ ]
and so yeah so we stand at the bar two
of my my bosses two of the top you know
guys
go into the next room and uh and lay
back and girls come to attend to them
and one of the guys is standing beside
me and a girl comes now i'm there trying
to talk to him he's saying yeah i want
to hear what you have to say go ahead
and i'm trying to talk to him about the
fact that the country is collapsing
while she unzips him and holds him out
and starts doing
and i'm sitting there trying to say i
mean you know the madness of the thing
i'm trying to say to myself what's
what's the protocol
when you're when you're down in the
capital to talk to your boss about the
collapse
of a country and the end you know the
united states first
total defeat
and your life and other people's lives
are in danger and your boss is getting a
[ __ ] you know are you supposed to
smile in his face and and encourage him
and you know come on and help him along
or should you you know look off at the
bar and pretend it's not happening until
he's finished you know what's what
nobody had ever taught me in marine
corps training or cia training what the
protocol for that was he still
carrying on his conversation to a point
eventually his eyes glazed over and he
kind of faded away
i went and sat out in the
the
anteroom outside until they were
finished and then they were saying you
go ahead there hadn't been enough girls
i guess and so you know you go ahead
we'll wait we'll have a beer and now
come on you know we gotta talk so we
went to lunch and then afterwards as
we're going back to the embassy they
want to drop me off so i can have mine
and i you know to hell with it and so i
go back to the embassy and fly back to
tainan
um
what they had said to me is yeah yeah
yeah yeah things are not as bad as you
think but we understand your position
you're up there on the front line and
you probably feel the pressure we really
admire you guys we really admire you
guys for your guts and sticking it out
up there don't worry when the crunch
comes you know we'll come and get you
don't worry a minute you know
so then the crunch comes and my boss
says that they haven't decided to
evacuate us yet
so i wait through the night and then the
next morning the attack still hasn't
come
so he says he'll fly up to review the
situation himself so he can make his
recommendations to washington
and so i'm you know we swept through the
night and and eight o'clock we over the
radio the codes and everything he's
supposed to be in the air he's taken off
he's on this and then he didn't arrive
what he did is on the way up there he
sees the uh
the arvind 25th division command post
and so he decides to land there
and talk to them about whether it would
be safe to fly on 12 more miles up to my
post and i just told him it was safe to
come and get us then
but he decides to stop well
unfortunately arvin has engaged the
enemy arvin's in the middle of a pitched
battle and it's within our artillery
range of of the communist forces so this
shiny
silver air america chopper lands and
immediately all hell breaks loose and
all the mortar rounds and artillery
rounds start landing on the headquarters
the arvind commanders dunk down in their
their bunkers and the pilot takes off
and my boss just barely has time to get
on the plane and get back in the air
so they panic and instead of coming to
get me they conclude it's not safe so
they go back home
and then he gets on the air you know
finally the call you know we're sitting
there where is he it's a 30 minute
flight he's been airborne for 30 minutes
an hour an hour and a half has he been
shot down you know what's going on
finally comes on the air and he says i'm
in vienna and i'm saying what the hell
are you doing in vienna and he said mind
you artillery is rumbling big shells
going off all around us and all this
stuff and we figure the tanks are on
their way into town
um
i said i tell him you know i tell i tell
him again it's safe send the plane back
to get us and he says well we have a
problem now air america is refusing to
fly because it's too dangerous and
they're civilians and they're not being
paid come that time
and so i'm saying well what do you
propose for us to do and he said well
you don't have any choice but to sit
tight and we'll work on the problem down
here
so we sweated through the day and that
night now i knew that there was one
person in the whole of vietnam that i
could depend on to get some sanity and
the cables going to headquarters and
also get an air america pilot and force
them morally to come up and get us and
that person was me
and but to do that i had to get down to
to benwa to saigon and so i jumped on a
vinaf
ammunition plane that was going back
and flew back to to bjanwa and i went in
and immediately i just told the boss
that you know this this i mean when he
was confronted by me he was a coward and
he didn't
he didn't resist i went and got an
america pilot and said we're going back
and their first reaction was like hell i
said no no i just flew out of there i'm
going with you i'll show you how to fly
it's safe we got to get these people out
and if i would go with them they flew
back and we went back and got my people
and went down to vienna
and then that was when i got down to
myanmar right after that experience that
i found that the cowards from yatrang
had been put in positions over us
and how many days was this before the
fall of saigon this was about uh two and
a half weeks so you left the province
that you were in and went to the saigon
area
and so you experienced the last two and
a half weeks of the war i was not i was
not mind you on the embassy rooftop in
the day the last day or two of the fall
of saigon i left a few days before that
that was what i had proposed to be was
part of that group
but so that i because i want to try to
keep on getting my people out
but that was the that was the last
battle that i lost was selling myself on
being able to stay with the last group
they they wouldn't have me for the
obvious reason i was committed to
getting people out and they were
committed to leaving people behind
i was committed to an orderly insane
withdrawal and they were committed to
polgar's madness of
telling the communist all our plans and
leaving our people behind and leaving
the files behind and mind you when we
left saigon the ci burned its own
internal codes and the famous six
million dollars they burned in cash
but
all of their operations that they had
run
with army intelligence and with the
special branch of the police had been
done from safe houses and all of those
files were intact and that included
every operation in the country and what
was the response of martin pogar and the
other u.s officials once they saw that
saigon was going to fall how did they
finally handle this and what it was
their response
the confusion and panic up to the last
day martin was still trying to pretend
that there would be some phone call from
the communist that would say
okay cool it that it was all going to be
coming as pressure that they're going to
get the pressure very intense but let
the americans stay
the the
they didn't believe it until the
artillery round started landing in
saigon
and mind you and then they panicked and
left
we had been shelled every day for months
without ever panicking but when the
rounds began to land in saigon then then
polgar and martin
panicked
and what about the south vietnamese gov
was there much resistance to the
no there was no fight there was no
battle for saigon as as a matter of fact
the ci had forced a change in
governments in the last few days to try
to give the north uh a face-saving way
to say well you know it's a new
government general men
would but see that that was the ci's
ploy
based on the pulgar philosophy thesis
which
could never have worked because it was
never in the communist plans
when they when the the communist uh
colonel you know
took the tank at the palace you know the
colonel went in he actually was a
correspondent he was a nva colonel but
he was in charge of the radios
he went to uh uh
he was the one who confronted men who
walked in and men said uh his a little
speech about i i surrender i yield the
powers and and the guy said no you don't
you don't have any powers to yield
we are the powers
john as you were leaving
vietnam after all you'd gone through and
flying back on the plane and all that
what was going through your mind
at at the at the end my final
[Music]
mental state was i felt like my mind had
been raped
or my soul had been raped if it's
possible to conceive of such a thing i i
felt violated
i
the things that i had believed in
in terms of honor and integrity
the the things that had led me to
volunteer into the marine corps and try
it to get into the elite units in the
marine corps and then get into the cia
which i understood was the elite of our
foreign service
had all been violated by the conduct of
my leaders
in vietnam
the the
what they had done to prevent us from
reporting the truth
uh the games they had played giving our
information to the communists
leaving our people behind when we could
just as easily have saved them mind you
170 000 vietnamese got out at that time
and into the states and another hundred
thousand you're talking about almost 300
000 people left in those weeks safely
we certainly could have brought out all
our people all it would have taken was a
decision from the ci director and the
station chief
to say find ways to save people and we
would have done it everybody could have
done it
these things
i couldn't live with what we had done
i flew out eventually in the dark of
night on a c-130 from tunsinute
and while we were flying on the way to
clark air force base
in manila the pilot relayed the message
to us that president ford had signed an
amnesty that any vietnamese could come
into the states anybody
and so i realized you know that i could
have brought all of my people out just
like that
but i didn't they were left behind and
they've been in reindoctrination centers
ever since uh let me put it this way i i
processed with my friends i processed
through
uh the refugee camp at
manila just like a refugee i went
through the law just sitting there i was
my mind it just shut down
because you know my five months of being
shelled every day and closing my post
and closing vienna
then fleeing saigon and losing all the
battles to save my people and seeing the
corruption and the stress and everything
i just shut down and i was i was laying
in a cot with all of these thousands of
vietnamese refugees and an american here
and there
and the guys with clipboards would come
around you know and they would be
looking for your papers and i'd hold up
my passport he would say but this is a
diplomatic passport and i i'd say yeah
you know they'd write down some stuff
and go away and come back and ask me
some more questions
eventually they came back and said are
you john stockwell and yeah well you see
my passport well
your headquarters was asking about you
and i said well here i am so they sent a
message saying i was safe they were
checking off all the names of everybody
eventually somebody came with a
clipboard and said you're on a plane
tomorrow morning to go back to the
states and so i got up and went uh
went back to the states but i had lane
in that cot looking at that tent for
five days
just uh
shut down and just shut down
well this began a period of agonizing
reappraisal of a lot of your views and
of what you've been doing and i guess
this will be the topic of the next show
that we'll do with you
thank you john
in our next program with john stockwell
he'll tell us about his recent and very
extensive trip to vietnam very few
americans have been back there since the
war is over
we have some people to thank for tonight
our director david galicic our camera
person judy burton and austin community
television ac tv for the use of their
equipment
alternative views is a presentation of
the alternative information network po
box 7279 austin texas
78713
if you enjoyed tonight's program with
john stockwell we've done a lot of
programs with him so if you'd like to
see some of them repeated
we'll just write to this address and
we'll
see what we can do to arrange it
good nine
you